Серед українців, які виїжджають на роботу за кордон, може побільшати медиків.
Сусідня Польща суттєво спростила умови працевлаштування для іноземних лікарів.
Приводом для нововведення став брак медиків в країні та пандемія COVID-19.
За оцінкою Вищої лікарської палати Польщі, нині у країні не вистачає 68 тисяч лікарів та 40 тисяч медсестер.
А середній вік, приміром, педіатра в Польщі зараз - більше 65 років.
Тож дитячих лікарів, а ще анестезіологів, терапевтів, радіологів, пульмонологів потребують найбільше.
Наприкінці року Сейм проголосував за законопроєкт про медичні кадри та вніс поправки до ковідного акту.
Обидва документи мають на меті залучити до Польщі іноземних медиків.
Здебільшого розраховують на фахівців з України та Білорусі.
Раніше, щоб отримати право працювати в польській лікарні, іноземні лікарі, в тому числі й українці, мали пройти чотири етапи.
Спочатку скласти іспит на знання польської медичної мови, нострифікаційний екзамен у польському медичному виші,
яким фактично підтверджували український диплом. Потім на них чекав рік роботи в лікарні під наглядом колеги-куратора.
А по його завершенні українські лікарі складали ще й тестовий іспит.
З підтвердженим дипломом медики з України могли легко знайти роботу за спеціальністю у польських лікарнях.
Однак увесь процес займав у середньому 1,5-3 роки та коштував декілька тисяч євро.
За новим законом, лікарі, які мають щонайменше 3 роки досвіду у своїй спеціалізації й хочуть переїхати до Польщі,
можуть не підтверджувати свій диплом та не здавати жодних екзаменів.
Міністерство охорони здоров’я Польщі вимагає від них лише завірений польським консулом диплом,
підтвердження від роботодавця про готовність працевлаштувати іноземця,
а також достатній для спілкування з пацієнтами і колегами рівень володіння польською мовою.
Щоправда, після ухвалення рішення міністерством медики-іноземці
повинні будуть пройти річне стажування в медичному закладі, як це було раніше.
Полегшені умови стосуються тільки працевлаштування лікарів.
Для середнього медичного персоналу та інтернів аналогічні правила
діють лише у випадку працевлаштування у ковідних відділеннях польських лікарень.
Для них спрощена система діятиме тільки на період пандемії,
а по її закінченні вони зможуть допрацювати свій контракт і повернутися додому.
За новими умовами українські лікарі можуть отримати обмежене право на лікарську діяльність.
Йдеться про дозвил на роботу лише на 5 років.
Упродовж цього часу медики мають підтвердити свій диплом за стандартною процедурою
або ж по закінченні трудового договору залишити Польщу.
Лікарі-мігранти не мають права змінювати місце роботи,
на яке дало дозвіл Міністерство охорони здоров’я,
чи просити про підвищення зарплати, погодженої на початку роботи.
У випадку звільнення ліцензія на лікарську практику анулюється і фахівець має повернутися на батьківщину.
А при втраті працездатності на медиків-іноземців, які мають обмежене право на лікарську діяльність,
не розповсюджуватимуться норми трудового права і їм не виплачуватимуть компенсації.
Відтак компанії, що займаються навчанням та працевлаштуванням у Польщі лікарів-мігрантів з України,
не очікують масового відтоку медичних кадрів до сусідів.
Кажуть, змінами радше скористаються ті фахівці, які вчили польську та планували переїзд за стандартною схемою.
Тепер вони зможуть розпочати роботу раніше,
а нострифікацію диплома робити, вже живучи в Польщі і працюючи за фахом.
Основною причиною, яка може таки зумовити відтік персоналу з українських лікарень,
є велика різниця між оплатою праці медиків в Україні та Польщі.
За даними Національної служби здоров'я України, середня зарплата лікаря в державних лікарнях
становить 9 тисяч гривень брутто, а середнього медичного персоналу - 7,5 тисяч.
За прогнозами рекрутингових компаній, лікарі, що влаштовуватимуться на роботу в польські клініки,
скориставшись новими умовами, матимуть чисту зарплату 2 тисячі євро на місяць.
Медсестри зможуть заробляти тисячу євро, яка може бути подвоєна,
якщо працювати з ковідними пацієнтами чи значно збільшена за рахунок додаткової оплати чергувань.
Утім, це вдвічі менше, ніж отримають польські медики аналогічних
спеціальностей чи іноземці, які нострифікували диплом.
У польському медичному середовищі перспективи полегшеного працевлаштування іноземних колег,
зокрема українців, викликали неабиякі дискусії.
Лікарські профспілки та громадські організації заявляють,
що допускаючи до лікування пацієнтів медиків-іноземців без перевірки їхньої кваліфікації,
керівництво Польщі наражає громадян своєї країни на небезпеку.
А відповідальність за життя хворих перекладають на польських лікарів,
які куруватимуть роботу українських та інших іноземних колег.
Однак самі польські медики в останні роки активно виїжджають на роботу до Німеччини,
Великобританії, Швеції та інших країн ЄС.
Тож залучення українців та білорусів - чи не єдиний спосіб
заповнити тисячі вакантних позицій в закладах охорони здоров’я Польщі.
За інформацією вищої лікарської палати, зараз у державних лікарнях Польщі працює понад триста українських лікарів,
ще кілька десятків працевлаштовані у приватних клініках.